landing a role in a superhero movie can
launch an actor into a world of fame and
fortune or even revive a floundering
career
sadly however that's not always the case
here are some superhero movie stars
hollywood seems to have stopped casting
before the mcu the dark knight trilogy
or even the original x-men movies there
was blade
back in 1998 wesley snipes starred as
the titular marvel vampire hunter
a hero whose unique lineage gives him
all the strengths of vampires and none
of their weaknesses
snipes reprised the role for two sequels
but after 2004's blade trinity things
slowed down considerably for the actor
for a number of reasons
for one snipes fell into some serious
legal trouble
in 2008 he was convicted on three counts
of willful failure to file federal
income tax returns and was sentenced to
three years in prison
although the actor was allowed to serve
the final three months under house
arrest
but even before his legal troubles
snipes built a reputation for being nigh
on impossible to work with
in a 2012 av club interview snipes
trinity co-star patton oswald revealed
some eye-opening stories about the actor
including the fact that he would
communicate with the movie's director
exclusively through post-it notes signed
from blade
he was also constantly stoned on set and
refused to open his eyes whilst filming
one scene
hence this
in recent years snipes has been working
to rebuild his career and he appears to
be making some headway
in 2019 he appeared in the netflix
original dolomite as my name and he's
set to star opposite eddie
murphy in the comedy sequel coming to
america whether things are truly turning
around for the actor however has yet to
be seen
in the mid-aughts it looked like jessica
alba would be on hollywood's a-list for
a long time to come
and she owed a good deal of her success
to comic book movies
alba was tapped to play susan storm in
2005's fantastic four
and that same year she played the
knockout dancer nancy in 2005
sin city the adaptation of frank
miller's edgy crime comics
suddenly however alba fell off the radar
according to alba herself a big part of
the problem was that she rarely got to
sink her teeth into challenging leading
parts
most of her work was in supporting roles
and many of them featured in poorly
received movies
this equals to both fantastic four and
sin city tanked for example as did most
of her later projects
in a number of interviews over the years
alba has gone back and forth on whether
or not professional acting is a priority
for her anymore
though it's clear she isn't making the
mark on hollywood she once did
she's currently starring in the crime
drama series la's finest the spin-off of
the bad boys films
considering its embarrassing aggregate
score of seven percent on rotten
tomatoes however it doesn't seem like
it's going to be launching alba back
into the a-list anytime soon
before the marvel cinematic universe was
born with 2008's iron man
sam raimi's spider-man movies were
probably the most prolific and
well-loved superhero movies around
and long before andrew garfield or tom
holland even began their careers tomi
maguire had become one of the definitive
superhero movie stars
pizza time while 2002 spider-man and its
2004 follow-up were critical and
commercial hits
2007 spider-man 3 ended the franchise on
a deafening down note
helped by the popularity of the first
two films spider-man 3 at least made
money but both fans and critics were
deeply disappointed
raymie wanted to make spider-man 4 to
redeem himself but that movie never came
to be
spider-man 3 was a serious body blow to
maguire's acting career
he's enjoyed a few leading roles since
but none have reached the prominence or
success of the spider-man flicks
of course maguire has partly
transitioned from starring in films to
producing them
and since spider-man 3 the actor has
spent more time behind the camera than
in front of it
maybe that's just where he's happiest
time will tell if marvel fans are
destined to see an x-force film or
deadpool 3 hit theaters but if these
movies do see the light of day you can
lay some pretty safe bets that tj miller
won't be involved in either
the actor and comedian played wade
wilson's friend weasel in the first two
deadpool films but his acting career
dried up quickly in 2018
miller's trouble started back in 2017
when it was reported he wouldn't be
returning to the hbo series silicon
valley
the show's creative team told vulture
the following year that miller was often
drunk or high on set
and that some days he wouldn't even show
up for work later in 2017
much more serious allegations arose from
a woman claiming miller had sexually
assaulted her in college
finally in march 2018 miller was
arrested for allegedly calling in a fake
bomb threat
deadpool 2 producer lauren schuler
donner said that by the time the sexual
assault allegation surfaced it was too
late to remove miller from the film
but there were signs his role had shrunk
considerably in september 2018
ryan reynolds confirmed that fans
shouldn't expect to see miller in
x-force
miller has since said he's contractually
obligated to appear in deadpool 3 if
disney asks him to be in it but
well don't hold your breath okay so jim
carrey may not be the first actor you
think of when you hear the phrase
superhero movie stars but he's done more
than his fair share of time in the comic
book trenches
in 1994 he starred as an unstable
superhero with shape-shifting powers in
the mask
the following year he played the riddler
in batman forever and in 2013 he
portrayed colonel stars and stripes in
the hyper-violent superhero comedy
kick-ass too
there was a time when a carry comedy was
an automatic moneymaker while some of
his dramas are among the most beloved of
all time
and it's true carrie still makes movies
today but he's not the a-lister he used
to be
these days most of his movie work comes
in the forms of supporting roles in
cameos
there are a few reasons for carrie's
diminished presence in hollywood
for one he's proven fairly difficult to
work with his method acting antics
during the making of man on the moon had
become the stuff of legend
he also refused to help promote kick ass
too because he wasn't comfortable with
the film's violent tone
especially in the aftermath of the sandy
hook killings for another in more recent
years carrie seems perfectly happy to
remain outside the spotlight and on a
number of occasions he stated that he
feels no real urge to make himself any
more famous than he already is
while terence howard played james rhodes
in 2008's iron man it was don cheadle
who donned war machine's armor in
subsequent marvel films howard has since
said that when marvel studios approached
him to renegotiate for iron man 2 they
offered him only 1 8 of what he was
originally promised
howard wasn't shy about expressing his
frustrations toward his friend and
co-star robert downey jr either though
the two would later meant fences
it turns out that the person that i
helped become
iron man took the money that was
supposed to go to me
and pushed me out in the meantime
howard's career didn't seem to suffer
too badly
he even landed the lead role of hip-hop
mogul lucius lyon on the musical drama
empire
despite empire's successful six season
run howard announced in 2019 that he was
going to quit acting for good
so far his reasons for the change have
been unclear mainly because his
responses about the decision in
interviews have been
rather strange for example during an
interview on the red carpet at the 2019
emmy awards howard explained that
i was able to open up the flower of life
and find the real wave conjugations that
we've been looking for for 10
000 years he went on to say that when he
opened the so-called flower of life
i found a whole new world of wave
conjugations that expose the in-between
spaces
it's not particularly clear what howard
means by that but one of the
consequences of the opening of the
flower of life is apparently that he's
going to give up being an actor
can't argue with that kevin spacey
turned out to be one of the more
memorable parts of a fairly forgettable
superhero movie when he replaced gene
hackman as lex luthor in 2006's superman
returns but spacey isn't likely to find
work on a superhero movie or any other
kind of movie anytime soon
that's because spacey has since become
one of the most loaded villains of the
me2 movement
after actor anthony rapp told buzzfeed
news in 2017
that spacey had made unwanted advances
toward him when he was only 14
spacey claimed he had no memory of the
event and apologized for what he called
quote
deeply inappropriate drunken behavior
more allegations followed including
accusations of sexual harassment and
assault from the likes of harry dreyfuss
filmmaker tony montana and crew members
from the spacey-led netflix series house
of cards
as a result of the allegation spacey's
acting career has come to a swift and
decisive end
netflix fired spacey from house of cards
and announced it wouldn't release the
netflix original film gore
in which spacey played the late gore
vidal even though the crime thriller all
the money in the world was already
filmed by that point
spacey was removed from the film and
director ridley scott re-shot all of
spacey scenes with christopher plummer
for all intents and purposes kevin
spacey's hollywood career is dead
and buried aaron eckhart has the
distinction of playing an important
supporting role in one of the best
superhero movies ever made the actor
famously played harvey dent in 2008's
the dark knight
but despite receiving critical acclaim
for that role and a number of others
eckard has never quite taken off as a
leading man in hollywood
he's taken a few shots at becoming an
action hero over the years but most of
those movies were commercial and
critical failures
unfortunately eckhart's attempts to find
a successful niche probably hasn't been
helped by his apparent
inability to work well with others in
2016 eckhart admitted to the guardian
that he'd once unleashed what he called
the quote
quintessential lashing out on an extra
who was supposedly falling asleep during
the actor's monologue
beyond that he told the telegraph that
he has a terrible reputation because
in his words he's quote just too intense
for people he went on to admit that he's
often highly competitive with his
co-stars too
and likes to pick them apart during
filming maybe it's no wonder people are
reluctant to work with him
in 1989's batman kim basinger played
vicki bale a photojournalist dying to
get a photo of batman without knowing
she's actually dating him baysinger has
had a long and impressive career
including an academy award for best
supporting actress win for her portrayal
of lynn bracken in the 1997 neo-noir
crime film la confidential
weirdly enough however she hasn't worked
since 2018.
early in her career basinger became a
sex symbol she played one of james
bond's many conquests in 1983's never
say never again
she was one half of the steamy pairing
in the 1986 erotic drama nine and a half
weeks
and she mostly only appeared in films as
a male hero's love interest
speaking to elle in 2015 basinger
discussed how being typecast is every
hero's main squeeze ultimately hurt her
career
the main problem seems to be that in
more recent years she has only been
hired to play mothers and wives
along with being typecast in this way
baysinger has said in interviews that
she suffers from extreme social anxiety
which makes it difficult to play the
networking game in hollywood in 2016 she
told netaporte that the moment most
actors dream about
accepting her academy award was
genuinely terrifying
for the time being it seems like
basinger is happy to have stepped out of
the limelight
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
bye